tomorrow night when monday night is over
between the bears and the steelers chris
that means we are exactly halfway
through the season
it goes fast right does go fast
since we are almost halfway through the
season we figured it was a good time uh
to hand out some mid-season awards
individuals on the field some coaches as
well some rookies so let's start with
the mvp and this is an interesting
choice
because of what happened tonight uh but
according to point spent tom brady is
the favorite josh allen had a tough day
he's just behind kylie murray didn't
play today
stafford we'll talk about him in a
moment dak prescott it was not a good
thing to be on this list no it would
kind of at least
right there right today it definitely
did i mean josh island murray prescott
nothing good stafford is my pick to win
the mvp but of course yes it was not a
good night i know that but again i'm not
going to just make a reaction off of one
game he's been phenomenal throughout the
whole year he's made the rams a
different football team all together
because it doesn't have to just be about
running the ball and bootlegs i know it
didn't look like that way against the
tennessee titans tonight touchdown the
interception ratios is about as good as
anybody in football it's quarterback
ratings have been as good as anybody in
football he still makes a ton of plays
and big throws in the pocket i mean
did we think did everybody just think
the rams are going to be seven and two
and have this type of offense with
matthew stafford i remember hearing a
lot of people like whoa now we'll see
what stafford's all about i don't know
you were on it right away though well
yeah we're as excited as thank you for
giving me that yes i was excited for it
i think it came you know came to life
even faster than i expected and again i
know tonight was strugglesville for for
matthew stafford he did some dumb stuff
tonight there's no doubt about that but
for the season he's been pretty on point
i'm gonna guess uh we're gonna see what
he said after the game that he
had pretty good accountability for what
happened with the usually he does here
he is
can you take us through those um two
turnovers yeah i mean the first one um
you know guys got a hold of me i gotta
do a better job just
probably just falling on that one or uh
you know throwing it over robert's head
maybe earlier i was trying to maybe get
back through it but
um can't have that i basically spotted
him 14 points i mean can't do that in
the nfl especially against a good team
like that that wants to you know get out
in front run the football mix coverages
do all that kind of stuff so
just wasn't good enough early in the
game
turnovers really you know killed us and
those were on me so
um you know if i clean those up and i
know i will
i got a lot of confidence in this team
to go out there and play some you know
really good football our defense played
good you know good enough to keep us in
the game good enough so really you know
if we don't turn the ball over twice um
you know gives us a chance to win that
one so uh got to play better myself uh
you know first and foremost
with the way the tennessee defense
played tonight against matthew stafford
i was reminded it's the same group that
kept patrick mahomes the only three
points here recently right they've got
some things figured out they do they're
good up front they're creative coach
they have game plan specific defensive
schemes on a week to week basis one week
cover four might look like this the next
week cover four looks a little different
you know that's where they're special
and paul i know you and i have talked
about a little bit you know during our
podcast sessions together that they're
one of the best zone defenses in
football they really understand how to
pass people off from one area to the
next and that led to a lot of stafford
struggles tonight yet some dumb
decisions but certainly let's give
credit to the titans defense too
absolutely from a team defense playing
extremely well let's go down to
individual defenders time to pick a
defensive mvp at the halfway point of
the year miles garrett the favorite tj
watt in pittsburgh right behind him then
you have diggs donald and ramsey
is your pick coming off this my bit my
pick is my i'm going with chalk here i
mean i think it's miles garrett to me
miles garrett's been the best defensive
player in football this year you know
he's very good against the run but you
could see one on one around the edge i
mean he's he's reached the aaron donald
status of almost unblockable when he's
one on one you have to have a plan for
myles garrett he's just too big he's too
fast he's disrupted we saw that again
today against joe burrow and the bengals
so it's the first time in a while i
think we've gotten to this point of the
year where i haven't got no aaron
donald's definitely the defense mvp
always finally somebody challenging him
a little bit here and yeah i go with
miles garrett for sure we spend so much
time in the spring talking about the
rookies to be and getting to know them
i'm glad that we're going with rookies
of the year as well at our halfway point
of the season picks so are we beginning
with the offense over the defense how
about
rookie of the year on the left side we
have offense jamar chase way out in
front and on defense
micah parsons even further out in front
on that side the defense is a no-brainer
it's not even a discussion i don't think
i mean michael parsons is definitely the
defensive rookie of the year michael
parsons is already one of the best
linebackers in football period i mean
he's one of the best defensive players
in the league he can do everything rush
the passer defense and cover linebackers
or running backs out of the backfield
you know fill the a gap and take it on a
full back and get him off you and then
tackle the tail back there's nothing he
can't do he's a phenomenally i mean a
big human being but incredibly athletic
and you could see how he could chase the
ball down and then paul did you say
chase just to get you i mean
i mean i'm going to chase just because
no i didn't i'm not that smart i take
myself there like that but jamar chase
for what he has done this year i mean
he's been arguably the most explosive
wide receiver in football made a few
mistakes today i know that but man one
on one week after week jamar chase has
been amazing i want to give matt jones
some love naji harris of course been
good for the steelers but nobody's made
the impact for their offense as a rookie
like jamar chase and remember that big
discussion should they go with the wide
receivers
they go with the offensive tackle
halfway through the season they
certainly made it you did right right
for cincinnati yeah i think you have a
lot of good choices for coach of the
year and i'm curious to find out which
one you think is best kingsbury at the
top john harbaugh always does a good job
mike grable has been excellent sean
payton too and brandon staley in his
first year with the chargers who's your
guest a lot of guys to pick from right
there hey one guy i wish was on that
list too is matt lafleur i mean how many
years in a row do the packers have to be
good and he has to manage like
dysfunctional situations before he gets
some love here i'm gonna go with cliff
kingsbury here as well and trust me
everybody i didn't see these graphics
before i picked these i picked these
first all right but kingsbury you know
we've talked before the year this is a
hot seat year they had to do something
they had to get in the playoffs and yeah
they have a good roster built by steve
kind but cliff kingsbury has grown as a
play caller i think he's understanding
how to manage the game a little bit even
if they don't get big plays
you know we've talked about in certain
weeks where they can be patient and go
on 15 play your 15 play drives so i give
cliff kingsbury with a lot of pressure
on him a lot of credit for what he did
damn it's like that right there it's
nice right it's a good looking lineup
and i want to say one more thing about
cliff kingsbury get you to say one more
thing
we were talking before the season
started about how much you like kyler
murray but you needed cliff kingsbury to
do a little more to help him put him in
better spots yes what has he done and
colt mccoy did it today too right what
has he done to kind of answer that call
i think it's more formation usage it's
not just four wide receivers and kylo
murray in the shotgun play after play
you know we talked about that a lot last
year it was very easy to break them down
i think as the season went on you know
they gotten better on the offensive line
which has allowed cliff kingsbury and
company to be more physical stay true to
the running game oh you want to play
past defense to stop kylo murray fine
here's chase edmonds here james o'connor
and then you know and then the ability
to when teams took away the big plays
cliff kingsbury's had an inventory of
offense and ways to find five yard
completion six yard completion eight
yard completion so that's what i really
love and that's what i meant about
helping kyler murray out and we've seen
kyla murray of course play better
football because i think he's got a few
more advantages schematically now not
just a little bit better he's played a
whole lot better no doubt kingsbury
calling the game that way we invite you
to download the points bet app and get
better odds daily promotions and betting
options you won't find anywhere else
points bet live your bet life
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports